Jack what can I help you with okay so my
question Gary is um I work in the
service of providing industry
copywriting and um what is your opinion
on my providing value more often
obviously I have no like products relate
to give away um obviously I see a lot of
people on like Google+ and Twitter just
sharing good articles every day but like
what are other ways that service
providers can give more value every day
I got a great idea how many customers do
you have um about like 15 clients and
rotation every month in and out awesome
I think you should call them all today
and ask them what you could do for them
that would help their business I like
that what about unlike um you know like
social media like they want your socks
no stay put stay put okay that that your
15 customers and like finding out one by
one individually what they give a crap
about is what you're wanting to do it's
what you should be doing got it got it
that's it like yes you could put out
content and you can become but that's
noise there's a ton of noise tons of
people put out content right yeah what
you have is no exactly this is why I
keep saying that b2b is easy I really go
agree to be so easy i'm your customers
are all [ __ ] Ricky today at the
company until what can I do for you
Ricky I love it I love it perfect but
you know what the funniest part is let
me give you a weird little kind of tweak
here JP you ready for it yes mean it ah
right yeah that's the funny part right
it can't be a tactic so when they give
you an answer go and execute I love it
cool me too
what that's how [ __ ] gets done uh-huh do
it you know what don't do it here's how
this is why it's epic to do these five
hour things Jack you need to help me
here go do it hold them all like seven
or eight of them come back in like two
hours tell everybody what's going on
okay done well single event make sure
you tweet it's done one I think he's
trying to build up his twitter follow
get back in here we'll find you all
right
like edit like you know two hours in so
Jack a lot of the people just answered
they would been here let's recap you got
in i gave you a piece of advice you take
over to story from here yeah um so i
have 15 clients and rotation I'm a
copywriter and I just keep them in
rotation every month you know and I hit
one up and he came back with a thousand
dollar contract and I also got a brand
new client oh you don't hear some like
texts proof of like this [ __ ] don't know
it that way that [ __ ] going down so yeah
thank you Gary and I'm about to order
right now by boat so how many books
shack how many were you in for I want
seven Jack I [ __ ] got you a thousand
dollar contract ah six hmm all right
wait I actually have my stuff to go back
and make it seven now hey guys zac
something you don't let me ask you a
question to really make it funny like so
what you learned anything is it
interesting like like what like talk to
me a little bit here like there's a
bunch of people here have been rocking
the whole time like what was it like
like what was interesting about that if
anything to you like it's we are right
like you decide to be on screen cast
with me we you know I give you this
piece of ice you go out and do it and
like you actually [ __ ] made money
because of it like what like what do we
like what do we think like talk to me
well I have to say that sometimes you
never know when a deal is on the table
when it could be and just you haven't
reached out and you know I some of them
i sent out some you know articles that
they love some information I know they
love and just add it in a little extra I
think at the back hold on Jack hey a
cuny hold on how do you said something
interesting i'm paying attention you
sent emails to everybody did you call ya
know I called three of them but almost
all of them are work right now they all
have you call three of them and what
happened all three said I can't speak
you right now
one of them texted me back is the one I
showed you that's the one that we are
have a solid deal I still think that you
should call the other people I think
they here's what I hear I hear they made
of G we're happy blah blah blah but what
I hear as BB being me I hear there's 12
[ __ ] people winning call yeah well i
get 3 30 ride in for time so I'm just
you need to call these people leave a
[ __ ] message the effort matters Jack
the effort matters this is gonna be a
bigger day I don't give a [ __ ] of a
thousand we're going for 5,000 you're
gonna kill it today please call the
other 12 people jack thank you promise
awesome thanks a common have a great day
orders coming in thanks jack all right